Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余味》。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，比如咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得像是在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自己做。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Space, the final frontier. These are the voyages of the Starship Enterprise. Its five-year mission, to explore strange new worlds, to seek out new life and new civilizations, to boldly go where no man has gone before. Ah. Oh, Jesus.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。太空，最后的边疆。这是星际飞船“进取号”的航行。它五年的任务，是探索陌生的新世界，寻找新的生命和新的文明，勇敢地航向人类从未踏足的地方。啊。噢，天哪。
Ah. Anyway, so that is, Dominic, the introduction to Star Trek. I know you're not a fan. Definitely not a fan now. But why have we begun an episode on Captain James Cook by introducing Captain James Kirk? And the answer is because Gene Roddenberry, who obviously came up with the idea of Star Trek, was a massive, massive fan of Captain Cook. And Captain Kirk is modeled on Captain Cook. And Captain Kirk is modelled on Captain Cook.
啊。总之，多米尼克，这就是《星际迷航》的开场白。我知道你不是粉丝。现在肯定不是了。但我们为什么要用詹姆斯·柯克船长的介绍来开启一集关于詹姆斯·库克船长的节目呢？答案是，吉恩·罗登贝里，也就是《星际迷航》的创作者，是库克船长的超级大粉丝。柯克船长是以库克船长为原型的。柯克船长是以库克船长为原型的。
And the Enterprise is the Endeavour. And Mr. Spock is Joseph Banks, the science officer. I should apologise to the listeners for what they've heard. William Shatner, of course, is himself a man with very dubious audio background, isn't he, Tom? Because he did those terrible cover versions. So did Leonard Nimoy the ballad of Bilbo Baggins yeah Bilbo yeah
“进取号”就是“奋进号”。而史波克先生就是科学官约瑟夫·班克斯。我得为听众们刚才听到的内容向他们道歉。威廉·夏特纳本人当然也是一位音频背景非常可疑的人，对吧，汤姆？因为他翻唱了那些糟糕的歌曲。伦纳德·尼莫伊也一样，唱了《比尔博·巴金斯之歌》，对，比尔博，对。
no we don't need to hear it thank you save that for the club members Tom so yes I'm just so sorry about all that however let's
不，我们不需要听那个，谢谢，留给俱乐部会员吧，汤姆。所以，是的，我真的很抱歉，不过让我们
pick up from where we were last time we're talking about the life and times of Captain Cook and specifically his first voyage to Australia
从上次讲的地方继续，我们正在谈论库克船长的生平与时代，特别是他第一次前往澳大利亚
and New Zealand but could I just add on the Star Trek thing it's not just the great thing and times of Captain Cook and specifically his first voyage to Australia and New Zealand. But could I just add on the Star Trek thing? It's not just, I mean, the great thing in Star Trek is that Captain Kirk and his crew on the Enterprise, when they're going across space, have to bear in mind the prime directive, which is a charge not to interfere with alien civilizations, not to give them their technology and things like that. And that again is a concept that derives from the challenges that face Captain Cook. And just as Captain Kirk throughout Star Trek cheerfully ignores this, so he'll kind of go down and get out his laser gun and blow things up and get off with aliens and all kinds of things. This is an issue
和新西兰的航行。但我能补充一下关于《星际迷航》的事吗？不仅仅是……我的意思是，《星际迷航》最棒的地方在于，柯克船长和他在“进取号”上的船员在穿越太空时，必须牢记“最高指令”，即不得干涉外星文明，不得向他们提供技术之类的东西。这同样是一个源自库克船长所面临挑战的概念。正如柯克船长在《星际迷航》中总是愉快地无视这一点，他会走下去，掏出激光枪，炸毁东西，和外星人鬼混，做各种各样的事。这是一个问题，
as well for the crew of the Endeavour, is it not, throughout this voyage? It is indeed, and we're going to get into this almost immediately. So if you remember from the last episode, Captain Cook has been given the mission of going off to Tahiti to establish an astronomical post to observe the transit of Venus. And if you want to know the astronomical details of this, the rationale for it, you obviously would listen to our previous podcast. Yes. Well, you spelt that out in immense detail. Yeah.
对于“奋进号”的船员来说也是如此，不是吗，在整个航行过程中？确实如此，我们马上就会深入探讨这一点。所以，如果你还记得上一集的内容，库克船长接到任务前往塔希提岛建立天文观测站，以观测金星凌日。如果你想了解其中的天文细节和基本原理，显然你应该去听我们之前的播客。是的。嗯，你已经非常详细地阐述过了。是的。
Very clear. Very clear. Good. But also, of course, he has these secret sealed instructions, which is that if he discovers the fabled great southern continent, Terra Australis, then he is to claim it for Great Britain. Because of course, hanging over this the whole time is the fear that some other European rival, not least the French or perhaps the Spanish, will get there first. And so that sort of sense of urgency, I think, there is a sort of low-level urgency there the whole time. So we ended last time with Tierra del Fuego. They leave Tierra del Fuego and the people covered with seal oil, and they sail out into
非常清楚。非常清楚。很好。但当然，他还有那些密封的秘密指令，即如果他发现了传说中的南方大陆——“未知的南方大陆”（Terra Australis），那么他就要将其宣布为大英帝国的领土。因为当然，整个过程中一直笼罩着一种恐惧，即其他欧洲竞争对手，尤其是法国人或西班牙人，会捷足先登。所以那种紧迫感，我认为，一直存在着一种低水平的紧迫感。所以我们上次结束时讲到了火地岛。他们离开火地岛，那些身上涂满海豹油的人，然后驶向
the unknown, into the Pacific, and they pass all these sort of little islands and atolls. They got into the Pacific on the 21st of January, 1769. And they're at sea for months, huge stretches of time pass where effectively nothing happens. To understand Cook's mentality and the challenges of life on the Endeavour, you have to take into account the fact that everything takes so long. There are long periods at sea. It's very, very cramped. It's incredibly cramped.
未知之地，驶入太平洋，他们经过了所有那些小岛和环礁。他们于 1769 年 1 月 21 日进入太平洋。他们在海上航行了几个月，大段大段的时间过去，实际上什么也没发生。要理解库克的心理和“奋进号”上的生活挑战，你必须考虑到一切都需要这么长时间。在海上航行的时间很长。非常、非常拥挤。简直拥挤不堪。
Very difficult conditions sometimes, storms. However, they do have milk because they have their goat. They have their goat. So the goat is now halfway around its second circumnavigation of the world. So the goat is more experienced than any of them, actually. Yeah. But on the 11th of April, Tom, they reach Tahiti. Some of them think this could be part of, this could be the sort of northern part of
有时条件非常艰苦，有风暴。不过，他们确实有牛奶，因为他们有山羊。他们有山羊。所以这只山羊现在已经完成了它第二次环球航行的一半。所以实际上，这只山羊比他们任何人都更有经验。是的。但在 4 月 11 日，汤姆，他们到达了塔希提岛。有些人认为这可能是
the great southern continent, which of course it isn't. And Tahiti, of course, is famously beautiful. And Joseph Banks says, the scene we saw was the truest picture of an Arcadia of which we were going to be kings that the imagination can form. So, I mean, that's immediately, it's an Arcadia and we're going to be the kings in it. But actually, Tahiti is not Arcadia. It's not an Eden because it has its own history. It has its own dynamics. And part of those dynamics are the fact that actually Europeans have been visiting it quite a lot. So Endeavour is the third European ship to arrive in Tahiti within the previous 18 months. And so part of what the fantasy is that this is virgin land, that the Tahitians are unspoiled by contact with the outside world. They're not at all.
南方大陆的一部分，当然事实并非如此。而且塔希提岛当然以美丽著称。约瑟夫·班克斯说，我们看到的景象是想象力所能构想出的最真实的阿卡迪亚（世外桃源），而我们将成为那里的国王。所以，我的意思是，这立刻就成了一个阿卡迪亚，我们要成为那里的国王。但实际上，塔希提岛并不是阿卡迪亚。它不是伊甸园，因为它有自己的历史。它有自己的动态。而这些动态的一部分事实是，欧洲人其实已经频繁造访过它了。“奋进号”是过去 18 个月内第三艘抵达塔希提岛的欧洲船只。所以，这片土地是处女地、塔希提人未受外界接触影响的幻想，其实根本不是这样。
What's more, that guy who had sailed before, Samuel Wallace, he had told Cook, hadn't he, before Cook left, he had said, you have to be careful of a couple of things first of all as is always the case when you stop at an island the locals will want to trade with you and your men will want to trade with them and in particular the locals will want iron yeah so they want nails they want nails again this is the kind of the prime directive thing of don't give your technology to the people that you meet with so that always has to be very strictly regulated because it can soon tip over into thieving into arguing into quarrels all this kind of stuff so that's one thing you also don't want to be have your men stealing from the ship stores to sell things to the locals or giving them weapons for example yeah and secondly an issue that
更重要的是，那个之前航行过的人，塞缪尔·沃利斯，他在库克离开前告诉过库克，不是吗？他说，你必须小心几件事。首先，正如你在岛上停靠时总是会发生的那样，当地人会想和你以及你的船员进行贸易，特别是当地人会想要铁。是的，所以他们想要钉子，他们想要钉子。这又是那种“最高指令”的问题，不要把你的技术给那些你遇到的人，所以这总是必须受到非常严格的监管，因为它很快就会演变成偷窃、争吵、纠纷，所有这些事情。所以这是一件事。你也不想让你的船员从船上的仓库里偷东西卖给当地人，或者给他们武器，例如。是的，其次，一个问题
runs right throughout this you'd mentioned captain kirk getting off with aliens there is always a sort of sexual dimension to this isn't there so there is throughout all of these voyages there is the issue of all these men who've been cooped up um on the ship absolutely desperate to get out and interfere with the local women and there is money to be made there are nails to be gained there is money to be made. There are nails to be gained. There is iron to be gained from either the local women effectively selling themselves to the sailors or their husbands, fathers, whoever, effectively. I mean, I hate to say it, Tom the course of his various voyages, he returns to various places and discovers that the sexual economy is becoming more and more sophisticated and is horrified by this. And the other thing that horrifies him, and again, this is a kind of running theme throughout all three of the voyages that he does, is he's terrified that Europeans will introduce venereal disease. And this again
贯穿始终，你提到了柯克船长和外星人鬼混，这里总有一种性方面的维度，不是吗？所以，在所有这些航行中，都有一个问题，那就是所有这些被关在船上的男人，绝对渴望出去，去干涉当地女性，而且有利可图，有钉子可赚，有利可图。有钉子可赚。无论是当地女性实际上把自己卖给水手，还是她们的丈夫、父亲，无论谁，实际上都能获得铁。我的意思是，我不想这么说，汤姆，在他各种航行过程中，他回到各个地方，发现性经济变得越来越复杂，并对此感到震惊。另一件让他感到震惊的事情，同样，这是他所做的所有三次航行中贯穿始终的一个主题，就是他非常害怕欧洲人会引入性病。这又
is a kind of running anxiety. So I think it's telling that when the endeavor arrives at Tahiti, basically everyone takes a Tahitian lover except for Cook himself. And we don't know why. He never says. So it could be that he is committed to his marital vows. He seems to have been very devoted to his wife. But it could also be that it's expressive of his horror at the idea of the risk of contaminating Tahitans or all the other native peoples that in due course they'll meet with with venereal diseases or it could be that it's just you know he's making a statement of the fact that he is above yeah the rest of the crew that he's holding on to his discipline that he is the captain and he has to uphold kind of points of difference i mean it could be all three of course tom but i think that last point offers the most sort of acute insights Cook. Cook is a man throughout whose self-control, his self-discipline, his status as the captain, all those things matter enormously to him. He never really lets himself go, does he? Until his very final voyage, which we won't
是一种持续的焦虑。所以我认为很能说明问题的是，当“奋进号”抵达塔希提岛时，除了库克本人，基本上每个人都找了一个塔希提情人。我们不知道为什么。他从没说过。所以可能是他忠于自己的婚姻誓言。他似乎对他妻子非常忠诚。但也可能这表达了他对污染塔希提人或他们以后会遇到的所有其他原住民的性病风险的恐惧，或者可能只是，你知道，他在声明一个事实，即他高于其他人，他保持着纪律，他是船长，他必须坚持某种差异点。我的意思是，当然可以是这三者，汤姆，但我认为最后一点提供了对库克最敏锐的洞察。库克是一个自控力、自律性、作为船长的地位，所有这些对他来说都极其重要的人。他从不真正放纵自己，对吧？直到他最后一次航行，我们这周不会讲，也许明年会讲，他在压力下确实开始有点崩溃了。但在这一点上，他约束自己，就像他想约束他的船员和世界一样。所以从这个意义上说，他不是柯克船长。他确实尽力维护“最高指令”。奇怪的是，皇家学会给他的指令中有一种“最高指令”的特质，他们绝对明确要求他不要惹麻烦，不要干涉。他应该只是观察。当然，基本上这是不可能的，因为你不能只是出现并保持中立。当然，这是人类学——欧洲人类学科学——的伟大发现之一，即你
be doing this week, we'll be doing perhaps next year, where he does start to unravel a bit under the pressure. But in this point, he regulates himself just as he wants to regulate his crew and the world, actually. So in that sense, he's not Captain Kirk. He does do his best to uphold the prime directive. And weirdly, there is a kind of quality of the prime directive to his instructions from the Royal Society, who are absolutely clear that he is not to cause trouble, that he's not to interfere. He is supposed to simply observe. And of course, basically, that's impossible because you can't just turn up and be neutral. And this, of course, is one of the great discoveries of anthropology, the European science of anthropology, is that you
不能仅仅进行观察。观察的过程本身就会改变社会。从一开始，这些互动就总是充满了危险，不是吗？总是存在误解、争吵的可能性。你知道，当他们第一次上岸时，约瑟夫·班克斯的亲信，索兰德博士，某种瑞典科学家，还有船上的外科医生，一个叫蒙克豪斯的人，他们在第一次上岸时发现他们的口袋被掏了，丢失了一些歌剧眼镜和一个鼻烟盒，那种东西被拿走的问题，对水手来说似乎太离谱了，对库克来说似乎太离谱了，这贯穿了所有的航行，以及对私有财产的不同态度和关于盗窃的争论，特别是我的意思是这些巨大的剧透警告。是的。这些将一直困扰库克到他生命的最后一天。库克一方面非常清楚皇家学会给他的指令，
can't just observe. The very process of observing changes societies. And right from the beginning, these interactions are always pregnant with danger, aren't they? There's always the possibility of misunderstandings, of arguments. You know, when they go ashore for the first time, Joseph Banks' kind of crony, Dr. Salander, sort of Swedish scientist, and the ship's surgeon, a guy called Monkhouse, they discover on that first trip ashore that their pockets have been picked and they've lost some opera glasses and a snuff box and that issue of things being taken which to the sailors seems so outrageous and cook seems so outrageous that runs right through all the voyages and the different attitudes to kind of private property and arguments about theft in particular i mean these massive spoiler alerts. Yeah. These are going to dog Cook to the very last day of his life. And Cook is, on the one hand, he's very cognizant of his instructions from the Royal Society
即他绝不能以任何方式干涉。同时，他意识到自己作为一艘英国船只船长的尊严和地位，从不怀疑在任何时候他都必须向他访问的人明确他作为一名军官所拥有的强大力量，即他访问的人必须毫无疑问地知道英国的火力。这其中存在着不可避免的紧张关系。库克显然很难处理。嗯，很早就发生了一次争吵。有人偷了一把火枪，或者一个塔希提人试图偷一把火枪，海军陆战队被命令开火，他们确实开了火，罪魁祸首被
that he should not interfere in any way. At the same time, he's aware of his dignity and status as a captain of a British ship and never doubts at any point that he has to make clear to the people that he's visiting the awesome power that he commands as an officer, that the people that he is visiting have to be left in no doubt what the firepower of Britain is. And there's an inevitable tension there. It's difficult for Cook to negotiate, clearly. Well, there's an altercation quite early on. Somebody steals a musket, or a Tahitian tries to steal a musket, and the Marines are ordered to open fire, which they do, and the culprit is
当场击毙。即使在那时，班克斯实际上也说，向他们开火是非常愚蠢的。他说，如果我们和这些印第安人吵架，我们甚至无法和天使相处。悉尼·帕金森，那位艺术家，他说，真遗憾，这种残暴行为——当然，这是他的话——真遗憾，这种残暴行为竟然被文明人施加在手无寸铁、无知的印第安人身上。所以你看到了那种屈尊俯就，显然，欧洲人高高在上的屈尊俯就，但也有一种遗憾，即他们的垄断、他们远为优越的技术和他们的暴力力量，离被使用从来都不远。而且库克和其他军官经常会诉诸
shot dead. And even at that point, Banks actually says, that was very foolish to fire on them. He says, if we quarrel with these Indians, we wouldn't agree with angels. Sidney Parkinson, who is the artist, he says, what a pity that such brutality now, of course, these are his words, what a pity that such brutality should be exercised by civilized people upon unarmed, ignorant Indians. So there you have the condescension, obviously, the towering condescension of the Europeans, but also a sense of regret that their monopoly, their far superior technology and their powers of violence, they're never far from being used. And that quite often Cook and other officers will resort to
暴力，因为他们觉得他们需要立下规矩并划定界限。当然，这是有代价的。但这就是作为船长的库克所承受的压力。我的意思是，他必须在这些浅滩中航行，而班克斯则不然。所以班克斯实际上在塔希提岛过得很愉快。我的意思是，他有一个问题，就是他带来的艺术家，一个叫亚历山大·布坎的人，在他们抵达塔希提岛后不久，就癫痫发作，陷入昏迷并去世了。班克斯对此感到心烦意乱，不是因为布坎去世了，而是基本上因为这就像度假后不久丢了 iPhone。他没有人可以拍出相当于
violence because they feel that they need to lay down a marker and to draw a line. And of course, that comes at a cost. But this is the pressure on Cook as the captain. I mean, he has to negotiate these shoals, whereas Banks, for instance, doesn't. And so Banks is actually having, he's having a lovely time on Tahiti. I mean, he has one problem is that the artist that he's brought, a man called Alexander Buchan, shortly after they arrive in Tahiti, has an epileptic fit, goes into a coma and dies. And Banks is distraught at this, not because Buchan has died, but basically because it's like losing his iPhone shortly after going on holiday. He doesn't have anyone to take the equivalent to
照片的东西。所以他对此非常难过。所以他说，他对我来说是不可挽回的损失。我梦想着向我在英国的朋友们展示我所见到的景象，这些轻飘飘的梦想已经破灭了，这非常清楚地说明了他悲伤的原因。但他过得很愉快。所以，例如，他看到了前所未有的耸人听闻的东西，欧洲人从未见过。如果他们见过，他们也没有描述过。他谈到这种非凡的塔希提习俗时说，我们站着欣赏这美妙的景象整整半个小时。你知道那是什么吗？我知道，因为我看过笔记。继续，告诉听众。我们站着欣赏这美妙的景象整整半个小时。你知道那是什么吗？我知道，因为我看过笔记。
photographs. So he's very upset about that. So he says, his loss to me is irretrievable. My airy dreams of entertaining my friends in England with the scenes that I am to see have vanished, which makes very clear what the cause of his grief is. But he's having a wonderful time. So for instance, he sees something sensational that no European has seen before. If they have, they haven't described it. And he says of this extraordinary Tahitian custom, we stood admiring this wonderful scene for full half an hour. Do you know what that was? I do because I've seen the notes. Go on, tell the listeners. We stood admiring this wonderful scene for full half an hour. Do you know what that was? I do, because I've seen the notes.
继续，告诉听众。所以这是双体独木舟到达的时候，是吗？不。噢，我在看笔记的另一部分。是冲浪。噢，是的，当然，冲浪。约瑟夫·班克斯是第一个观察到冲浪的人。是的。
Go on, tell the listeners. So this is when the double canoe arrives, is it? No. Oh, I'm looking at a different part of the notes. It's surfing. Oh yes, of course, the surfing. Joseph Banks is the first to observe surfing. Yeah.
所以我认为这是我们第二次在《历史的余味》中提到冲浪。第一次当然是阿加莎·克里斯蒂，她是一位热衷冲浪的人。没错，但班克斯看着它，你知道，他看到了冲浪，他被它迷住了，我相信如果他在那里待得更久，他也会开始冲浪的，他会成为一名出色的冲浪者。所以汤姆，我以为你在说的是班克斯被一艘载着男人和……的独木舟靠近的时刻，是的，这也是一个伟大的时刻，男人和一些女人，男人给班克斯一些大蕉和一些树枝，然后他们把这些布铺在地上。其中一个女人走上前来，然后正如班克斯所说，他说了什么？
So I think this is the second time we've mentioned surfing in the rest of history. The first time, of course, being Agatha Christie, who was a keen surfer. that's right but banks watches it you know he sees surfing and he's transfixed by it and i'm sure that if he'd stayed there longer he would have taken it up he'd been an excellent surfer so tom what i thought you were talking about was the um moment when banks is approached by a double canoe with a men and um yes well this is also a great moment men and some women the man gives Banks some plantains and some branches, and then they spread these sheets on the ground. One of the women comes forward, and then as Banks puts it, what does he say?
她展示了她所有的魅力。她通过慢慢地转过身，给了他一个欣赏这些魅力的绝佳机会。她脱掉了所有的衣服，她有点向他露出臀部，而且做了三次，不是吗？是的，三次，然后她做这个动作的布被正式呈献给班克斯，他说他随后把她和另一个女人带到了他的帐篷里，并给了她们两人礼物，但我无法说服她们停留超过一个小时。所以非常像柯克船长。所以在那一个小时里发生了什么？是的，所以这是……我给了她们礼物，但我无法说服她们停留超过一个小时。所以非常像柯克船长。
She unveiled all her charms. She gave him a most convenient opportunity for admiring them by turning herself gradually around. She takes all her clothes off, and she sort of bears her buttocks to him and does this three times doesn't she yes three times and uh and then the cloth on which she did this is presented formally presented to banks and uh he says that he then took her and another woman to his tent and to both of them i made presents but i could not prevail upon them to stay more than an hour so very captain kirk so what happened in that intervening hour yeah and so this is um them I made presents, but I could not prevail upon them to stay more than an hour. So very Captain Kirk.
所以在那一个小时里发生了什么？所以这是，你知道，班克斯显然认为这是一种性暴露。正是这些报告在他们回到欧洲后，会传达出一种塔希提岛是自由恋爱之乡的感觉，并将以各种方式被解读。尼古拉斯·托马斯在他精彩的著作《发现》中提供了一种我认为对我来说听起来更合理的解释。他的论点是，那个女人展示的不是她的私处，而是她皮肤上的装饰，这是一种标记，图案，遍布她的臀部和私处。她通过拥有这些来证明，
So what happened in that intervening hour? And so this is, you know, Banks obviously assumes that this is kind of sexual exhibitionism. And it's reports like these that when they get back to Europe will convey a sense that Tahiti is a home of free love and it will be interpreted in all kinds of ways. Nicholas Thomas, in his wonderful book, Discoveries, offers a different interpretation of it that I think sounds more plausible to me. His argument is that what the woman is revealing is not her private parts, but the decorations on her skin, which are kind of markings, patterns, all over her buttocks and over her private parts. And she is demonstrating by the fact that she has these,
她已经到了可以就买卖布料和其他东西进行谈判的年龄。所以本质上她所做的是展示她的商业资格。她的资历。是的。这就像一种 MBA。当然，她身上的这些标记也是以后会对库克的船员、对皇家海军、最终对英国国内社会产生巨大影响的东西，因为塔希提语中这些标记的词是 tataau，班克斯将其转写为 tattoo（纹身），从而将“纹身”这个词引入了英语，并最终引入了许多其他欧洲语言。所以这就是为什么，汤姆，皇家海军水手与纹身联系在一起，多亏了库克和他的……是的，因为在航行过程中，一次又一次，库克和他的船员看到的波利尼西亚人都有这些纹身。
that she is of sufficient age to embark on negotiations over the selling and the buying of cloth and other things. So essentially what she's doing is she's presenting her kind of business qualifications. Her credentials. Yes. It's like a kind of MBA. And of course, these markings on her body are also something that will have a huge impact on Cook's crew in due course on the Royal Navy and ultimately on society back home in England, because the Tahitian word for these markings is tataau, and Banks transcribes this as tattoo, thereby introducing the word tattoo into the English language and in due course into lots of other European languages as well. So this is why, Tom, Royal Navy sailors are associated with tattoos, thanks to Cook and his... Yeah, because over the course of the voyage, again and again, the kind of Polynesian peoples that Cook and his crew are seeing have these tattoos.
他们变得越来越印象深刻。他们最终想，嗯，你知道，我们挺喜欢这个的。所以他们回去后，这就引发了时尚。所以到 18 世纪末，你知道，纹身已经成为水手的标志。汤姆，你没有纹身，对吧？我没有。我的意思是，这通常不是历史学家的事。历史学家丹·琼斯有纹身。他有很多纹身。实际上，丹·琼斯可能是英国唯一一个没有纹身的历史学家，对吧？我没有。我的意思是，这通常不是历史学家的事。历史学家丹·琼斯有纹身。
And they become more and more impressed by them. And they end up thinking, well, you know, we quite like a bit of this. And so they go back and this then generates the fashion. So by the end of the 18th century, you know, a tattoo has become the marker of a sailor. Tom, you don't have any tattoos, do you? I don't. I mean, it's not generally a historian. The historian Dan Jones has tattoos. He has loads of tattoos. Actually, Dan Jones is probably the only historian in Britain who doesn't have any tattoos, do you? I don't. I mean, it's not generally a historian. The historian Dan Jones has tattoos.
他有很多纹身。实际上，丹·琼斯可能是英国唯一一个没有自己播客的历史学家。但他确实有纹身。但他确实有很多纹身。所以也许你应该做一个关于它们的播客。所以冲浪和纹身。是的。班克斯对此非常了解。
He has loads of tattoos. Actually, Dan Jones is probably the only historian in Britain who doesn't have his own podcast. But he does have tattoos. But he does have lots of tattoos. So maybe you should do a podcast about them. So surfing and tattoos. Yeah. Banks is all over that.
当然，他在女士们面前是个花花公子。他是个花花公子。我的意思是，他是否为她们弹吉他，我不知道。库克认为，不是吗，他的手下会从当地人那里，实际上是从塔希提人那里感染性病，因为他说几周后，24 名海员和 11 名海军陆战队员中有 9 人都得了病。他认为这是性病。
And of course, he's being a cad with the ladies. He's being a cad. I mean, whether he's playing his guitar for them, I don't know. Cook assumes, doesn't he, that his men will have got venereal disease from the natives, actually, from the Tahitians, because he says after a few weeks, 24 seamen and nine out of the 11 Marines have all got disease. And he thinks it's venereal disease.
但实际上，不是。这是一种叫雅司病（yaws）的东西。你知道什么是雅司病吗？不知道。这是一种传染性很强的疾病，据称在整个太平洋地区都很流行。所以你的身体上会长疮之类的。好吧，但它不是性病？不。这是一种传染性很强的疾病，据称在整个太平洋地区都很流行。所以你的身体上会长疮之类的。好吧，但它不是性病。
But actually, it's not. It's something called yaws. Do you know what yaws is? No. It's a very infectious disease, which apparently was endemic all over the Pacific. So you get sores on your body and stuff. Okay, but it's not venereal? No. It's a very infectious disease, which apparently was endemic all over the Pacific. So you get sores on your body and stuff. Okay, but it's not venereal.
不。然而，说到性方面的事情，汤姆，多么可爱的联系。是的，太棒了。做得好。回到科学。6 月 3 日，备受期待的
No. However, talking of venereal things, Tom, what a lovely link. Yes, wonderful. Very well done. Back to science. On the 3rd of June, the much-anticipated
金星凌日发生了。他们能够进行所有的测量。一切都很顺利。他们现在知道了太阳系中的物体相距多远，这太棒了。工作完成得很好。库克准备庆祝。
transit of Venus happens. And they're able to take all their measurements. That all goes very well. They now know how far apart things in the solar system are, which is wonderful. A job well done. And Cook is ready to celebrate.
然后他发现他自己的手下，所以这是盗窃的事情，他自己的手下闯入了船上的仓库，偷了 120 磅的钉子卖给当地人，卖给塔希提人。我假设他们这样做是为了换取性服务，汤姆，因为你会猜那是他们想要的回报，不是吗？是的，我想是这样。
And then he discovers that his own men, so this is the theft thing, his own men have broken into the ship's stores and stolen 120 pounds of nails to sell to the natives, to the Tahitians. And I'm assuming they've done this in return for sexual favours, Tom, because you would guess that's what they want in return, wouldn't you? Yeah, I guess so.
有很多盗窃。有火枪、手枪被偷。但库克真的在努力巡逻。所以有一个屠夫威胁了一个塔希提妇女，他让他公开受鞭刑。是的，他确实这么做了。我认为，让所有这些球保持在空中，正如他们所说，是一个挑战。他对这件事的反应震惊了他的一些手下。所以例如，当他发现所有这些东西
There's a lot of thefts. There are muskets, pistols that are stolen. But Cook is really trying to patrol that. So there's a butcher who kind of threatens a Tahitian woman and he has him very publicly flogged. Yes, he does. It's a challenge, I think, to keep all these balls in the air, as it were. His reaction to this shocks some of his men. So for example, when he finds that all this stuff
都被偷了，比如耙子和水桶，他围捕了一大堆独木舟，并威胁要烧掉它们。他对塔希提人民的强硬路线让他的一些手下感到担忧，而班克斯并不赞成，例如。现在，你说班克斯，他这么说很容易，因为他没有面临这些困境。但危险总是欧洲人的过度反应会激起当地人的反应。当然，这就是库克在他第三次航行的最后几天里所面临的问题。确实是。
has been stolen, like a rake and a water cask, he rounds up a whole load of canoes and he threatens to burn them. And his hard line with the people of Tahiti worries some of his men, whereas Banks doesn't approve of it, for example. Now, you said Banks, it's easy for him to say that because he's not facing these kind of dilemmas. But the danger is always that a European overreaction will then provoke a reaction from the locals. And of course, that's the issue that Cook contends with in the very final days of his life in his third voyage. It is.
但在塔希提岛，我的意思是，他确实与塔希提岛上的许多人建立了良好的关系。你知道，胡萝卜加大棒，我想。是的。你知道，我们现在总是认为这些相遇是破坏性的、创伤性的，所有这些事情。但有一个因素，不是吗？这些相遇对双方的人来说都是极其令人振奋的。如果你是一个喜欢新鲜事物、对世界充满好奇的人，它们总是带有一定程度的模糊性和不确定性。
But in Tahiti, I mean, he does establish good relations with lots of people on Tahiti. You know, it's carrot and stick, I guess. Yeah. You know, we always perceive these encounters now. We see them as damaging, traumatic, all of these kinds of things. But there is an element, isn't there? These encounters were tremendously invigorating to people on both sides. If you're somebody who likes novelty, who is curious about the world, there is always a degree of ambiguity and uncertainty about them.
但显然库克本人，他觉得这些相遇很令人兴奋。班克斯绝对是。所以班克斯，他一直在外面。他有点在观察，你知道，看着纹身，邀请女士们进入他的帐篷谈判布料，
But clearly Cook himself, he finds these encounters exciting. And Banks absolutely does. So Banks is, he's out there all the time. He's kind of watching, you know, looking at tattoos and inviting ladies into his tent to negotiate over cloth
研究仪式，你知道，询问传统，试图工作，你知道，编写塔希提语和英语词典。他真的对此很着迷，并且可以以一种库克无法做到的方式投入其中，因为库克有太多其他事情要考虑。我猜你所谈论的紧张关系，
and studying the rituals and, you know, inquiring about the traditions and trying to work, you know, compile dictionaries of Tahitian and English. He is really fascinated by it and can kind of plunge into that in a way that Cook can't because Cook has so much else on his mind. I guess that the tension in what you were talking about,
塔希提人对欧洲人的迷恋，以及班克斯和其他欧洲人对塔希提人的迷恋，在 7 月 12 日发生的事情中得到了著名的体现。那是金星凌日后的第二天，班克斯记录说，其中一个岛民，一个叫图皮亚的人，想和他们一起走，他想在“奋进号”上看看世界。班克斯说，他可能会把他当作一个好奇心，就像我的一些邻居养狮子和老虎一样，花费比他可能花在我身上的要大。这是一个似乎象征着今天人们会不赞成的一切的陈述，
the fascination that Tahitians have with Europeans and that Banks has with, and the other Europeans have with Tahitians, is notoriously exemplified by something that happens on the 12th of July. So that's the day after the transit of Venus, where Banks records that one of the islanders, a man called Tupia, wants to come with them, that he wants to see the world on the endeavor. And Banks says that he might keep him as a curiosity, as well as some of my neighbors do lions and tigers at a larger expense than he will probably ever put me to. It's a statement that seems emblematic of everything that people today would disapprove
即启蒙运动项目，它是贪婪的，它把其他人降低到物体的地位。我认为这其中有一种方面。但同样，当你阅读班克斯的日记时，他从同样对他感到高兴的人身上获得的快乐，我认为也是显而易见的。所以它的复杂性，它不是好或坏。是的，我同意你的看法。这里面有各种各样的复杂阴影。我同意你的看法。这是一种模糊的关系。实际上，我刚才草草写下的词是
of the Enlightenment project, that it's acquisitive and it reduces other people's to the status of objects. And I think there is a kind of aspect of that. But equally, when you read Banks's journals, the delight that he is taking in people who likewise are taking delight in him, I think is evident as well. So the complexities of it, it's not good or bad. Yeah, I agree with you. There are all kinds of shades of complexity there. I agree with you. It's an ambiguous relationship. And actually, the words I just scribbled down were
屈尊俯就和好奇心。这两件事总是并存的，所以当然，欧洲人库克和他的手下认为自己是文明的，他们认为塔希提人民是落后的，我的意思是毫无疑问。然而同时，它并不纯粹，它不仅仅是一种屈尊俯就、居高临下的关系。他们也绝对被所有的仪式、所有那些东西所迷住。他们正在看到北约克郡没有人见过的事情，所有这些库克正在看到的东西。而且，卢梭关于欧洲原始资本主义文明的所有混乱、无礼和好奇心都应该被抛弃的想法。塔希提人体现了一种纯真，这又是一种幻想。这有点忽略了塔希提动态的复杂性。
condescension and curiosity. And those two things are always coexisting so of course the europeans cook and his men regard themselves as civilized and they regard the people of tahiti as backward i mean there's no doubt about that yet at the same time it's not pure it's not just a condescending, patronizing relationship. They also are absolutely fascinated by all the rituals, by all that stuff. They are seeing things that nobody in North Yorkshire has seen all this stuff that Cook is seeing. And also, the Rousseauian idea that all the clutter and the impertinences and the inquisitiveness of European proto-capitalist civilization is something to be cast aside. There's a kind of innocence that the Tahitans embody, which again is a fantasy. It's kind of ignoring the complexity
但正如你所说，这是一种非常、非常复杂的关系，一种悖论的矩阵。但你在库克和班克斯身上都看到了这一点，不是吗？他们的一部分是被吸引的。是的，而且在航行过程中会越来越被吸引。是的。所以我们可能应该休息一下，汤姆，因为我们还没有到达目的地。我们离目的地还很远，也就是新西兰和澳大利亚。但休息后我们会到达那里，并发现库克船长
of the dynamics in Tahiti. But as you say, it's a very, very complicated relationship, kind of matrix of paradoxes. But you see that in both with Cook and Banks, don't you? That there's part of them that is drawn. Yes, and will become increasingly drawn over the course of the voyage. Yeah. So we should probably take a break, Tom, because we haven't got to our destination. We're not really remotely near our destination, which is New Zealand and Australia. But we will get there after the break and discover what Captain Cook
对那两个辉煌的地方有什么看法。所以休息后我们会到达那里，并发现库克船长对那两个辉煌的地方有什么看法。所以休息后见。Chiara，在意大利语中意味着聪明。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，你的咖啡馆名字，Giulia。但你用得越多，就越觉得像是在接受证人保护。等等。
made of those two splendid places. So we will see there after the break and discover what Captain Cook made of those two splendid places. So we will see you after the break. Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Giulia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute.
Giulia 到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自己做。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在与库克船长一起勇敢前行，他一直在塔希提岛。他见证了金星凌日，一切都有点混乱，但他看到了塔希提岛上各种美妙和非凡的事物，但那段任务已经完成了。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are boldly going with Captain Cook and he has been on Tahiti. He's witnessed the transit of Venus and it's all been a bit of a mess, but he's seen all kinds of wonderful and extraordinary things on Tahiti, but that stretch of his mission is done.
现在他打开了海军部给他的密封信封。里面给了他具体的命令，他必须去发现“未知的南方大陆”。如果你未能发现上述大陆，你将在到达新西兰时，仔细观察该陆地所处的纬度和经度，并尽可能多地探索海岸，视船只的状况、船员的健康状况和补给状态而定。所以出于这个原因，他们前往新西兰。所以汤姆，他们知道新西兰存在，因为阿贝尔·塔斯曼在 1642 年曾航行环绕新西兰或新西兰的部分地区，但他因为担心当地人——毛利人——而被劝阻不要登陆，不是吗？弄清楚他到达新西兰海岸时该如何处理，但在他们到达之前，多米尼克，在 8 月 25 日，细心的听众可能记得在上一集中我提到班克斯带了一些柴郡奶酪，噢是的，问问波特啤酒，
And now he opens his sealed envelope that he's been given by the Admiralty. And in it, he is given the specific order that he has to go and discover Terra Australis Incognita. that if you shall fail of discovering the continent before mentioned, you will, upon falling in with New Zealand, carefully observe the latitude and longitude in which that land is situated and explore as much of the coast as the condition of the bark, the health of her crew, and the state of your provisions will admit of. So off they head to New Zealand for that reason. So Tom, they know that New Zealand exists because Abel Tasman had sailed around New Zealand or around parts of New Zealand in 1642, but he had been discouraged from landing because he'd been worried about the locals, the Maori, hadn't he? um work out how to handle when he arrives on the shores of new zealand but before they get there dominic on the 25th of august um attentive listeners may remember that in the previous episode i mentioned that uh banks had packed some cheshire cheese oh yes ask of porter
他带那个的原因是为了纪念他们离开英国的周年纪念日。所以在 8 月 25 日，他从储藏室里拿出了柴郡奶酪。他打开了波特啤酒桶。正如班克斯在日记中所说，它证明非常好，所以我们像英国人一样生活，并为我们在英国的朋友们的健康干杯。噢，那很好。那很好，不是吗？那是一个可爱的记录。所以总之，补充了波特啤酒和奶酪，他们在 1769 年 10 月 7 日瞥见了新西兰的海岸。
and the reason he'd taken that was to mark the anniversary of their departure from england so on the 25th of august he takes the Cheshire cheese from his larder. He taps the cask of Porter. And as Banks himself says in his journal, it proved excellently good so that we lived like Englishmen and drank the healths of our friends in England. Oh, that's nice. That's nice, isn't it? That's a lovely note. So anyway, replenished with Porter and cheese, they glimpsed the shores of New Zealand on the 7th of October, 1769.
所以这是来自帕金森的日记。他说，下午两点左右，我们的人之一，外科医生的男孩尼古拉斯·杨，从右舷船头描述了一个陆地尖端，距离约九里格，
So this is from Parkinson's Journal. He says, about two o'clock in the afternoon, one of our people, Nicholas Young, surgeon's boy, described a point of land from the starboard bow at about nine leagues distance,
向西偏北。我们向它驶去，日落时分，我们看得很清楚。我们款待了自己。晚上为了这个场合，这片土地被称为“杨尼克角”（Young Nick's Head），男孩得到了他的奖励。所以这是新西兰的北岛，
varying west and by north. We bore up to it, and at sunset, we had a good view of it. We regaled ourselves. In the evening upon the occasion, the land was called Young Nick's Head, and the boy received his reward. So this is the North Island of New Zealand,
他们最终降落在一个他们称为“贫困湾”（Poverty Bay）的地方。实际上，从一开始，他们就看到了人，不是吗？他们看到了毛利人，起初他们从他们身边跑开了。在第一次登陆时就发生了对抗，所以他们的人员有点分开了，有些人靠近船只，有些人去看了小屋，在回船的路上，库克和小屋的人，小屋团队，他们听到了枪声，他们回来后发现靠近船只的人向一群正在用长矛向他们推进的毛利人开了枪，
and they end up landing at a place that they call Poverty Bay. And actually, right from the start, they see people, don't they? They see Maori who run away from them at first. And at that very first landing there is a confrontation so their party kind of splits up there's some of them by the boats there's some of them that have gone to look at the huts on the way back to the ship cook and the hut people the hut team they hear shooting and they get back and they discover that the men by the boats have fired shots at a group of ma Maori who are advancing with spears at them
他们杀死了第一个毛利人，所以这是第一个死于欧洲人之手的毛利人，是一个叫特毛罗（Te Mauro）的家伙，那种……你知道，与毛利人的互动比与塔希提人的互动要困难得多，我们应该这么说，从一开始就是这样，不是吗，汤姆？是的，但在某种程度上，库克对毛利人的态度中反直觉的一面是，他似乎非常钦佩他们，所以他对发生的事情、关于杀戮感到非常难过，并且非常、非常渴望与他们建立关系，以试图修复损害。但他认为，在毛利人身上，有一种独立性，一种
and they have killed the first Maori so it's the first Maori to die at the hands of Europeans who is a chap called Te Mauro um and that that kind of you know the interactions with the Maori are much more difficult should we say than those with the people of tahiti right from the outset aren't they tom yes but in a way kind of the counterintuitive aspect of cook's attitude to the maori is that he he seems to have admired them hugely so he's very upset about what happens about the killings, and is very, very anxious to establish relations with them to try and repair the damage. But he also recognizes, I think in the Maori, a quality of independence, a kind of quality
英雄主义的品质，他非常钦佩。在适当的时候，会有关于食人族和各种各样事情的摩擦。库克将始终试图解释为什么毛利人会做在欧洲人眼中看起来令人震惊的行为。你可以从他关于这段航行和与毛利人互动的著作中看到，他对某种形式的文化相对主义的理解，一种承认他作为欧洲人的理解只是看待世界的一种方式，这通常看起来非常现代。是的。值得注意的是，他很好奇。我认为如果库克不是首先好奇的话，他就不会是库克了。他永远不会离开北约克郡。他永远不会
of heroism that he really admires. And in due course, there'll be brushes with cannibalism and all kinds of things. And Cook will consistently attempt to explain how and why the Maori do what might to European eyes seem shocking actions. And you can see over the course of his writings about this particular stretch of voyage and his interactions with the Maori, how his understanding of, I suppose, a kind of form of cultural relativism, a kind of a recognition that his understanding as a European is only one way of seeing the world, that does often seem very modern. Yeah. Remarkably, he's curious. I think Cook wouldn't have been Cook if he wasn't curious in the first place. He would never have left North Yorkshire. He would never
去海上。他永远不会加入皇家海军，所有这些事情。但他并没有停止，正如他们所说，自我教育。他对世界很感兴趣。在那次暴力事件发生后的第二天，他和他的手下再次登陆。他们现在发现了一大群毛利人，
have gone away to sea. He'd never joined the Royal Navy, all of those things. But he doesn't stop, as it were, educating himself. He's interested in the world. The day after that first violence, he and his men land again. They find a big party of Maori now,
出海远航了。他从未加入过皇家海军，诸如此类。但他并没有停止自我教育。他对这个世界充满好奇。在那次最初的暴力冲突后的第二天，他和他的手下再次登陆。他们现在发现了一大群毛利人，
about 100 people, who dance at them. They brandish their weapons, distort their mouths, lolling up their tongues and turning up the whites of their eyes. So this will be familiar to anyone who's watched the All Blacks. The All Blacks, exactly.
大约100人，他们跳着舞。他们挥舞着武器，扭曲着嘴巴，吐出舌头，翻着白眼。所以，任何看过全黑队（All Blacks）比赛的人都会对此感到熟悉。正是全黑队。
The whole are accompanied with a strong horse song, calculated, in my opinion, to cheer each other and intimidate their enemies and may with propriety be called a dancing war song. It lasted three or four minutes.
整个过程伴随着强有力的战歌，在我看来，这是为了互相鼓舞并威慑敌人，称之为战舞歌曲是恰如其分的。它持续了三到四分钟。
So this, as Tom says, if you watch the All Blacks rugby team, the New Zealand rugby team, perform the Haka before a match, this sounds remarkably like it. Now they have this guy from Tahiti, Tupia. Who is the guy that Banks had said, you know, I'll keep him as a curiosity. And an extraordinary thing that they can use Tupia. This is denying Tupia's agency, isn't it? I mean, that's the thing that Banks may think that he's bringing him as a curiosity, but actually to Tupia. Tupia's being incredibly intrepid and yes it's the endeavor that's the curiosity yeah that's true but they
正如汤姆所说，如果你看过全黑队，也就是新西兰橄榄球队在赛前表演哈卡舞（Haka），这听起来非常相似。现在他们有了一个来自塔希提岛的人，图皮亚（Tupia）。班克斯（Banks）曾说，你知道，我要把他当作一个稀奇之物留下来。他们能利用图皮亚是一件非同寻常的事。这是否在否定图皮亚的主体性？我的意思是，班克斯可能认为他把图皮亚当作一个稀奇之物带走，但实际上对图皮亚来说，图皮亚表现得非常勇敢，是的，这次探险本身就是一件稀奇的事，没错，但他们
can use him as a translator this is an extraordinary boon for them but also a stunning revelation to cook of the fact that tahiti is a long way from new zealand i mean it's a very very long way and yet clearly the same people who who in New Zealand linguistically are related to the people in Tahiti, which can only mean that they've sailed there. And so again, that is something that is eye-opening for Cook, the realization that his voyage of discovery, traversing these vast expanse of the ocean, Europeans are not the first to do it. Polynesians have done it.
可以把他当作翻译，这对他们来说是一个巨大的福音，但对库克（Cook）来说也是一个惊人的发现，因为塔希提岛距离新西兰非常遥远，我的意思是，那是非常非常遥远的距离，然而很明显，新西兰的这些人与塔希提岛的人在语言上是相关的，这只能意味着他们曾经航行到过那里。所以，这再次让库克大开眼界，他意识到他的发现之旅，穿越了如此广阔的海洋，欧洲人并不是第一批做到这一点的人。波利尼西亚人已经做到了。
And that again, I think is enhancing his sense of respect and admiration for the peoples that he's meeting. Yes. He gets Tupia to tell them, we are their friends. We've only come to get water and trade with them. And that if they offered to insult us, we could with ease kill them all. So there you have the combination, you see. He wants to be friendly, but we could kill you. But Tupia told us plainly that they were not our friends and told us several times to take care of ourselves and that that
而这一点，我认为再次增强了他对他所遇见的人民的尊重和钦佩。是的。他让图皮亚告诉他们，我们是他们的朋友。我们只是来取水并与他们进行贸易的。如果他们胆敢侮辱我们，我们可以轻易地杀死他们所有人。所以你看，这就是那种结合。他想表现得友好，但又说我们可以杀了你。但图皮亚明确告诉我们，他们不是我们的朋友，并多次告诉我们要小心，而且那
confrontation too ends in violence so cook and banks have brought along some beads and some nails um which they offer to the maori one of the maori steals a sword the british fire at them to try to disperse them banks is using a birdshot, which won't kill you. But the Marines eventually end up firing their weapons, and again, one of the Maori is killed. Later on, a mad thing to do, Cook's men try to capture a Maori canoe so that they can assure the canoeists that they mean them no harm. And as a way of capturing the canoe, they start shooting at it and kill four people.
场对抗也以暴力告终。所以库克和班克斯带了一些珠子和钉子，他们把这些东西提供给毛利人，其中一个毛利人偷了一把剑。英国人向他们开火试图驱散他们，班克斯使用的是鸟枪弹，不会致命。但海军陆战队最终还是开了火，结果又有一名毛利人被杀。后来，库克的人试图俘获一艘毛利独木舟，以便向划船者保证他们没有恶意，这简直是疯狂的行为。作为俘获独木舟的一种方式，他们开始向其射击，并杀死了四个人。
Yeah, this is very Captain Kirk. Yeah, and as Cook's biographer Richard Hoff says, to kill more than half a canoe load of intended detainees in order to cultivate a friendship with the natives appears to be an unbalanced calculation. Yeah. Which I think is fair enough. But actually, interestingly, they feel great remorse
是的，这非常有柯克船长（Captain Kirk）的风格。是的，正如库克的传记作者理查德·霍夫（Richard Hoff）所说，为了与当地人建立友谊而杀死了超过半船的预定被拘留者，这似乎是一个不平衡的算计。是的。我认为这评价很中肯。但有趣的是，他们确实感到非常懊悔
about this. I mean, I'm not excusing their behavior by any means, but they do feel remorse. Banks says, the most disagreeable day my life has yet seen. But again, it's not just that they're feeling remorseful at the casualties that they've inflicted. It's that they, or certainly Cook, is feeling hugely impressed by everything that he's seen. So I mentioned about the cannibalism. So they start to go up the New Zealand coastline, don't they? Starting to chart it. And Hoff calls this one of the great achievements in the history of hydrography. So I'll take his word for that. But in the course of this voyage, they keep coming across evidence of cannibalism one of the
对此。我的意思是，我绝不是在为他们的行为辩解，但他们确实感到懊悔。班克斯说，这是我一生中见过的最令人不快的日子。但同样，这不仅仅是因为他们对造成的伤亡感到懊悔。而是他们，或者至少是库克，对他所看到的一切感到非常震撼。所以我提到了食人行为。他们开始沿着新西兰海岸线北上，不是吗？开始绘制地图。霍夫称这是水文学史上最伟大的成就之一。所以我相信他的话。但在这次航行过程中，他们不断发现食人行为的证据，其中一个
sailors says saw one of the indians with the arm bone of a man eating the flesh from it uh several canoes alongside with indians one of which had four men's heads with the hair on and flesh very green they had dried them in the sun about three or four days one of which mr banks bought inevitably that's very banks behavior very banks Banks behaviour. But Cook, he says, notwithstanding they are cannibals, they are naturally of a good disposition and have not a little share of humanity. It's this sense that Europeans don't eat people, Maori do, whatever. Those are the customs of the world. I think it's important to say with the violence, his instinct is never to use violence initially. I mean, that's not why
水手说看到一个印第安人拿着一根人骨，正在啃食上面的肉；几艘独木舟靠在船边，其中一艘上有四颗人头，头发还在，肉色发青，他们在太阳下晒了三四天，其中一颗被班克斯先生买下了，这不可避免地是非常班克斯式的行为，非常班克斯式的行为。但库克说，尽管他们是食人族，但他们天性善良，且不乏人性。这是一种感觉，欧洲人不吃人，毛利人吃，无论如何，这就是世界各地的习俗。我认为必须指出的是，面对暴力，他的本能从来不是首先使用暴力。我的意思是，那不是他
he's come, is it? Actually, the Royal Society have specifically told him. They absolutely have. Do not land and start shooting the natives. I mean, don't forget, we'll be talking about, as we said last time, we'll be talking about Cortez and the conquest of Mexico. Those stories, which are only, what, 250 years previously, are very much in the minds of Europeans in the 18th century. And they're what Cook wants to avoid. And they're what they want to avoid, the black legend of Spanish sadism and corruption and all this kind of thing. And people like Cook think of themselves as better than that. They think, well, we're not the 16th century Spaniards. We are civilized, kindly people, enlightened people.
来的目的，对吧？实际上，皇家学会明确告诉过他。他们绝对告诉过他。不要登陆并开始射杀当地人。我的意思是，别忘了，正如我们上次所说，我们将讨论科尔特斯（Cortez）和墨西哥的征服。那些故事，仅仅是250年前发生的，在18世纪欧洲人的脑海中记忆犹新。而这些正是库克想要避免的。他们想要避免的是西班牙式的虐待、腐败等黑色传说。像库克这样的人认为自己比那更好。他们想，好吧，我们不是16世纪的西班牙人。我们是文明、善良的人，是开明的人。
Now, of course, they don't always live up to their own ideals, but they have a sense of themselves as not wanting to... They do, as you said, Banks used that word Arcadia about Tahiti. They do have a sense of this as a kind of lost Eden and one in which they don't want to willy-nilly interfere with the locals. Do you think that's fair, Tom? Well, so I think Cook is caught between two senses of responsibility. So as we said, he has these instructions from the Royal Society, don't fire, don't inflict violence. But at the same time, Cook, as an officer, is responsible for his men and is kind of determined to use force to demonstrate to people who might otherwise attack and kill his men that this is foolish. And I think he clearly feels, I mean, we know he does because he kind of hints at it in his journals. He's very anxious returning to England, that he will be judged badly by the Royal Society for this,
当然，他们并不总是能达到自己的理想，但他们有一种不愿……正如你所说，班克斯用“阿卡迪亚”（Arcadia）这个词来形容塔希提岛。他们确实有一种感觉，认为这是一个失落的伊甸园，他们不想随意干扰当地人。你认为这公平吗，汤姆？嗯，我认为库克夹在两种责任感之间。正如我们所说，他有来自皇家学会的指示，不要开火，不要施加暴力。但与此同时，库克作为一名军官，对他的手下负责，并且决心使用武力向那些可能攻击并杀死他手下的人证明这是愚蠢的。而且我认为他显然感觉到了，我的意思是，我们知道他感觉到了，因为他在日记中暗示过。他非常担心回到英国后，会因为这些伤亡而受到皇家学会的严厉评判，
that they will feel that he's failed because of the casualties that he's inflicted. But equally, he feels responsibility to his men. And that's the kind of the tension that he's wrestling with the whole way through. Anyway, that's New Zealand. So he has taken possession of it in the name of the crown. So above Queen Charlotte Sound, which is the very top of the South Island, kind of facing the harbour of Wellington, facing the North Island, Cook has built a cairn and he has hoisted the Union flag and he's taken formal possession of it.
他们会觉得他失败了，因为他造成了伤亡。但同样，他也对他的手下负有责任。这就是他始终在挣扎的紧张关系。总之，这就是新西兰。所以他以王室的名义占领了它。在夏洛特女王湾（Queen Charlotte Sound）上方，也就是南岛的最顶端，面对惠灵顿港，面对北岛，库克建造了一个石冢，升起了联合杰克旗，并正式占领了它。
I mean, not that any of the locals are listening. In the name of Queen Charlotte and of the King and for the use of his majesty, they've all drunk Queen Charlotte. That's George III's wife's health. A local Maori, an old man has come with them and is the only person to watch the ceremony. And they present him with the empty bottle. That's nice. And he apparently is delighted with this gift, delighted with it, and goes back home with his trophy. They circumnavigate both the islands, the North Island and the South Island. But they don't, I mean, whenever they land,
我的意思是，并不是说当地人有谁在听。以夏洛特女王和国王的名义，并为了陛下的使用，他们都喝了夏洛特女王的健康酒。那是乔治三世妻子的健康。一位当地的毛利老人和他们一起来，是唯一观看仪式的人。他们把空瓶子送给了他。那很好。他显然对这份礼物感到高兴，非常高兴，带着他的战利品回家了。他们环绕了两个岛屿，北岛和南岛。但他们并没有，我的意思是，每当他们登陆时，
there's always complications, aren't there? They haven't had the kind of relationship at all that they had on Tahiti. By the time they've circumnavigated it, which is March 1770, they're all keen to get on. Banks says the men began to sigh for roast beef, which is very 18th century conduct. And so now they're going to set off and set their course westwards towards what they regard as New Holland. Of course, they don't call it Australia then,
总会有麻烦，不是吗？他们根本没有像在塔希提岛那样建立起那种关系。到1770年3月他们环绕航行结束时，他们都急于继续前进。班克斯说，船员们开始渴望烤牛肉，这非常符合18世纪的行为。所以现在他们要出发，向西航行，前往他们所认为的“新荷兰”（New Holland）。当然，那时他们不叫它澳大利亚，
because they think Australia is probably going to be something else, don't they? They still think there might be another continent. So they leave- It's a shame it wasn't called New Holland, really. Oh, no, I think it's better as Australia. New Holland would be ghastly placed on. We'd never hear the end of it from you. I'd love it. Yeah, you and the real Tom Holland.
因为他们认为澳大利亚可能还会是别的东西，不是吗？他们仍然认为可能还有另一个大陆。所以他们离开——没叫它新荷兰真是可惜。哦，不，我认为叫澳大利亚更好。新荷兰听起来太糟糕了。我们永远听不到你对此的抱怨。我会喜欢的。是的，你和真正的汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）。
So they leave New Zealand, 31st of March, 1770. Two years now they've been away. And for two weeks they sail. Then they see the first signs of hints of land from the birds that are flying above them so birds that stop in the in that sort of perch in the rigging that they know must be land birds and then on the 19th of april 1770 a chap called zachary hicks climbs up in the the rigging he's always been very keen to be the first to see land and at six o'clock he shouts out land ahoy and this is the moment that uh it was that lovely reading wasn't that song their very first episode yeah cook
所以他们在1770年3月31日离开新西兰。他们已经离开两年了。他们航行了两周。然后他们看到了陆地的最初迹象，从飞过他们上空的鸟儿身上，那些停在索具上栖息的鸟儿，他们知道那一定是陆地鸟类，然后在1770年4月19日，一个叫扎卡里·希克斯（Zachary Hicks）的家伙爬上索具，他一直非常渴望成为第一个看到陆地的人，在六点钟，他大喊“发现陆地了”，这就是那一刻，呃，那不是我们第一集里那段可爱的朗读吗，是的，库克
recording in his journal that they have finally spotted the eastern coastline of new holland and cook's intention he will call it new south w. I think it's still unknown why South Wales. Do you know why it was called South Wales? No, I don't. I mean, no offense to South Wales, but it's not the first part of the British Isles that I'd name Newland after. Interestingly, and this will please our Kiwi listeners
在日记中记录他们终于发现了新荷兰的东海岸，库克的意图是他将称之为新南威尔士（New South Wales）。我认为为什么叫“南威尔士”至今仍是个谜。你知道为什么叫南威尔士吗？不，我不知道。我的意思是，对南威尔士没有冒犯之意，但它不是我命名新大陆时会想到的不列颠群岛的第一个地方。有趣的是，这会让我们的新西兰听众高兴，
and offend our Australian listeners, Cook says of Australia, visibly worse than the last place we were at which was of course new zealand that's great news for new zealanders isn't it it's not long before they start seeing signs of human habitation so they see uh smoke rising from fires and then in due course they that you know they go ashore because they need wood they need water and so on. And then they meet the Aboriginal inhabitants of Australia. And what's amazing about them is, say, unlike the Maori, certainly unlike the Tahitians, they show no interest whatsoever.
并冒犯我们的澳大利亚听众，库克谈到澳大利亚时说，明显比我们上次去的地方差，那当然是新西兰，这对新西兰人来说是个好消息，不是吗？没过多久，他们就开始看到人类居住的迹象，他们看到烟雾从火堆中升起，然后他们理所当然地上了岸，因为他们需要木材、水等等。然后他们遇见了澳大利亚的原住民。关于他们，令人惊奇的是，比如说，不像毛利人，当然也不像塔希提人，他们表现出完全没有兴趣。
So Cook writes, No one was once observed to stop and look towards the ship. They pursued their way in all appearances, entirely unmoved by the neighbourhood of so remarkable an object as a ship must necessarily be to people who have never seen one. And it's kind of expressive, clearly, of a determination on the part of the Aboriginal inhabitants of Australia to have absolutely nothing whatsoever to do with these peculiar people who have turned up and started raising flags everywhere. So to use your Star Trek trek parallel it's as though an alien spaceship descends on you know chipping camden and the people just don't even carry on they just
所以库克写道，没有人停下来看一眼这艘船。他们继续走自己的路，看起来完全没有被这艘船这个如此引人注目的物体所打动，而对于从未见过船的人来说，这必然是引人注目的。这显然表达了澳大利亚原住民的一种决心，即绝对不想与这些突然出现并到处升旗的奇怪的人有任何瓜葛。所以用你的《星际迷航》类比，就好像一艘外星飞船降落在卡姆登镇（Chipping Camden），人们甚至连看都不看，他们只是
carry on and say nothing had happened so when they finally arrive at what ends up being called botany bay so that's the 28th of april 1770 they sail along the shore they see people stark naked spearfishing doing their thing on the coast those people don't look up at them cook anchors the ship he goes inland and banks describes how then they're quite close to some huts and he says soon after this an old woman followed by three children came out of the wood she carried several pieces of stick and the children also had their little burdens she often looked at the ship but expressed neither surprise nor concern she lit a fire and four canoes came in from fishing they landed hauled up their canoes and began to dress their fish for dinner to all appearance
继续做自己的事，就好像什么都没发生一样。所以当他们最终到达后来被称为植物学湾（Botany Bay）的地方时，那是1770年4月28日，他们沿着海岸航行，看到人们赤身裸体地在岸边用矛捕鱼，做着自己的事，那些人没有抬头看他们。库克抛锚停船，他深入内陆，班克斯描述了他们当时离一些小屋很近，他说，此后不久，一位老妇人带着三个孩子从树林里出来，她拿着几根棍子，孩子们也有他们的小负担，她经常看那艘船，但既没有表现出惊讶也没有表现出关心。她生了一堆火，四艘独木舟从捕鱼回来，他们登陆，拉起独木舟，开始处理鱼作为晚餐，看起来
totally unmoved at us yeah and banks and cook who are so curious themselves about other people and other places are completely bewildered by this attitude from the Aboriginal Australians. But of course, Banks does have other things to keep himself busy, namely all the flowers that he finds in what comes to be called Botany Bay. And it has to be said that in general, the naming of places by Cook and his expedition, I mean, they're terrible. Poverty Bay. Poverty Bay. Yes. West Bay. Ship Bay. Cape Farewell. I mean, terrible names.
完全没有被我们打动。是的，班克斯和库克对其他人和其他地方如此好奇，却对澳大利亚原住民的这种态度感到完全困惑。但当然，班克斯还有其他事情要忙，即他在后来被称为植物学湾的地方发现的所有花卉。必须说，库克和他的探险队对地点的命名，我的意思是，太糟糕了。贫困湾（Poverty Bay）。贫困湾。是的。西湾（West Bay）。船湾（Ship Bay）。告别角（Cape Farewell）。我的意思是，糟糕的名字。
But Botany Bay is an excellent name, isn't it? Yeah, I think it's only an excellent name because we're used to it. Don't you think? No. I mean, if what if banks had been a historian, you'd call it History Bay. Yeah, but there's no history. But there's loads of flowers. So Botany Bay is great.
但植物学湾是个好名字，不是吗？是的，我认为它只是个好名字，因为我们习惯了它。你不觉得吗？不。我的意思是，如果班克斯是个历史学家，你会叫它历史湾（History Bay）。是的，但那里没有历史。但那里有很多花。所以植物学湾很棒。它不是历史湾。好吧，无论如何，他们上了岸。第一个上岸的人叫艾萨克·史密斯（Isaac Smith）。所以库克让他
Anyway. There's no history. Tom, that is the cancellation remark. Finally. No, no. I mean, there's no kind of evidence of history. It's not like there's a history museum or anything, but there's loads and loads of plants. So it's a botany bay. It's not a history bay. Well, anyway, they go ashore. The first man ashore is called Isaac Smith. So Cook lets his
妻子的侄子成为第一个上岸的人，这很好。他们上了岸，确实试图与澳大利亚原住民交流，但非常不成功，所以他们扔出珠子和钉子作为礼物，而原住民男人向他们扔石头，是的，所以进展不顺利，或者确实在一种情况下，一些家伙扔了几支矛，正如经常发生的那样，库克诉诸于向他们发射火枪或小弹丸。他们收集了一些矛。他们收集了一些文物。班克斯开始对当地的动物群非常感兴趣，不是吗？因为他发现了可能是澳洲野犬（dingo）的足迹。
wife's nephew be the first person to go ashore, which is nice. They go ashore and they do try to communicate with the Aboriginal Australians, butians but pretty unsuccessfully so they're throwing gifts of beads and nails and the aboriginal men throw rocks at them yeah so it's not going well or indeed in one case some of the fellows throw a couple of spears and as all as so often the way cook resorts to shooting muskets or small shot at them they They collect some spears. They collect some artifacts. Banks starts to get very interested in the local fauna, doesn't he? Because he finds the tracks of what is probably a dingo.
是这样吗，汤姆？你熟悉澳洲野犬吗？是的，我们稍后会谈到这个。他确实在适当的时候看到了澳洲野犬，但首先他们必须继续航行。所以他们从植物学湾向北航行，遇到了大堡礁（Great Barrier Reef），不是吗？哦，他们被困住了。他们被困住了。
Is that right, Tom? Are you familiar with dingoes? Yeah, we'll be coming to this. He does in due course see a dingo, but first they have to sail on their way. And so they head from Botany Bay northwards and they run into the Great Barrier Reef, don't they? Oh, they get stuck. They get stuck.
那是非常《星际迷航》的一集。有点像“进取号”（Enterprise）被困在什么地方。那是填充集。你没钱了。你没有预算请更多的演员。是的。他们最终在船上撕开了一个洞，他们不得不进去修理它。
That's a very Star Trek episode. Kind of like the Enterprise getting stuck in some. That's a filler episode. You've run out of cash. You haven't got the budget for more actors. Yeah. They end up kind of ripping a hole in the ship and they have to go in and amend it.
我的意思是，非常非常，我的意思是，他们非常接近彻底的灾难。但在修理船只的同时，他们确实，他们与原住民建立了更好的关系。所以显然，欧洲人第一次得知原住民的名字就是在这次机会。如果介绍理解得当的话，那个原住民叫亚帕里科（Yaparico）。你知道，这是第一次，他们算是进行了交流。而且著名的是，你谈到了动物。有一段关于一种奇怪野兽的对话，库克将其描述为“有灰狗那么大，形状各方面都像灰狗，有一条长尾巴，它像灰狗一样带着它，形状各方面都像灰狗，有一条长尾巴，它像灰狗一样带着它，简而言之，如果不是因为它走路或奔跑时像野兔或鹿一样跳跃，我本会把它当作一只野狗”，这是库克对这种奇怪动物的描述，班克斯描述
And I mean, very, very, I mean, they come very close to complete disaster. But while they are repairing their ship, they do, they kind of establish better relations with the Aboriginal peoples. So apparently the first time when a European learns the name of an Aboriginal person is on this occasion. And the Aboriginal person was called Yaparico, if the introductions were properly understood. You know, for the first time, they are kind of communicating. And famously, you talked about animals. There is a conversation about a peculiar beast, which Cook describes as the full size of a greyhound and shaped in every respect like one with a long tail, which it carries like a greyhound and shaped in every respect like one with a long tail which it carries like a greyhound in short i should have taken it for a wild dog but for its walking or running in which it jumped like a hare or deer that's cook on this strange animal banks describes
它说，要将其与任何欧洲动物进行比较是不可能的，因为它与我见过的任何动物都没有丝毫相似之处。库克和班克斯问当地原住民，这是什么动物？原住民回答说，这是对他回答的英语化，袋鼠（kangaroo）。所以他们，库克和班克斯，就称之为袋鼠。现在，人们常说库克误解了所说的话，原住民可能是在说，我不知道，什么？你不能用我的语言说话吗？或者类似的话。但显然，我在这里引用尼古拉斯·托马斯（Nicholas Thomas）的话，袋鼠不仅实际上是古吉伊米迪尔语（Googie Yimmy-deer）的近音转写，而且“奋进号”（Endeavour）航行的词汇表
it to compare it to any european animal would be impossible as it has not the least resemblance of any i have seen and Cook and Banks asked the local Aboriginal people, well, what was this animal? And the Aboriginal person replies, and this is the anglicisation of his reply, kangaroo. And so they, Cook and Banks, would call it as a kangaroo. Now, it's often said that Cook had misunderstood what was being said and that the Aboriginal person perhaps was saying, I don't know, what? Can't you speak in my language? Or something like that. But apparently, so I'm quoting Nicholas Thomas here, not only is kangaroo in fact a close transcription of the Googie Yimmy-deer word, but the Endeavour voyage word list of
中大约60个术语被最专业的当代学者认为是大致准确的。”哦。那很好。所以显然袋鼠确实是袋鼠。那很好。就在这时，班克斯看到了澳洲野犬，他还看到了狐蝠（flying fox）。这些与当地居民的最初互动，实际上，令人惊奇的是，当你阅读库克和班克斯的回忆录时，那种好奇心，我会说，我的意思是，屈尊俯就
some 60 terms is regarded by the most expert contemporary scholar as generally accurate." Oh. So that's good. So apparently a kangaroo really is a kangaroo. That's good. And it's at this point that Banks sees a dingo and he also sees a flying fox. These first interactions with the local inhabitants actually, the remarkable thing is that when you read Cook and Banks' recollections, that spirit of curiosity i would say is i mean the condescension
总是存在的，但比人们预期的要少得多。所以这是关于他们与原住民共进的第一次晚餐，他们邀请他们共进晚餐，但原住民实际上拒绝了，但库克说他们的特征远非令人不快，他们的眼睛很生动，牙齿整齐洁白，声音柔和悦耳，他们非常容易地重复了我们说的许多词，实际上他继续说，不是吗，他认为他们拥有极好的生活。是的，所以库克说，从我对新荷兰原住民的描述来看，在某些人看来，他们可能是地球上最悲惨的人，但实际上，他们比我们欧洲人快乐得多，因为他们完全不了解，不仅是多余的，甚至是欧洲人如此追求的必要便利设施。他们不知道使用这些东西反而快乐。他们生活在一种
is always there but it's much less pronounced than one might expect so this is about the first um that first dinner that they have with aboriginal people they invite them for dinner and the aboriginal people actually refuse but cook says their features were far from disagreeable their eyes were lively their teeth even and white their voices were soft and tunable and they repeated many words after us with great facility and actually he goes on to say doesn't he he thinks they have a tremendous life yeah so cook says from what i've said of the natives of new holland they may appear to some to be the most wretched people upon earth but in reality they are far more happy than we europeans being wholly unacquainted not only with the superfluous but the necessary conveniences so much sought after in Europe. They're happy in not knowing the use of them. They live in a
宁静中，这种宁静没有被条件的不平等所打扰。所以这再次是卢梭（Rousseau）的那种观点，即这是人类幸福的自然状态。我认为这表达了一种感觉，库克正在摸索，这就是为什么他们不注意船只、小饰品和他们给的东西，因为他们不需要它们。因此，这是他们幸福的基础。是的。他们不贪图宏伟的房子、家庭用品等。他们生活在温暖宜人的气候中，享受着非常健康的空气。所以他们几乎不需要衣服。然后他们说，当我们给他们布料时，
tranquility, which is not disturbed by the inequality of condition. So again, that's the kind of the Rousseau idea that this is the natural condition of happiness that humans have. And it's expressive, I think, of a sense that Cook is groping towards, that this is why they're not paying any attention to the ships and the trinkets and the things that they're giving, that they don't need them. And that therefore, this is the basis of their happiness. Yeah. They covet not magnificent houses, household stuff, et cetera. They live in a warm and fine climate and they enjoy a very wholesome air. So they have very little need of clothing. And then they say, when we gave them cloth,
他们并不在意。他们对布料没有用处。实际上，库克并不是以轻蔑的方式说这句话的。他对他们很着迷。不，他是钦佩它。是的，对它着迷。所以汤姆，他们在……离开澳大利亚，他们离开澳大利亚北端
they weren't bothered. They have no use for cloth. And actually, Cook doesn't say this in a contemptuous way. He's fascinated by them. No, he's admiring of it. Yeah, fascinated by it. So Tom, they leave Australia on the, they leave the north tip of Australia
大约在8月20日、22日。然后他们接下来要去哪里？他们前往巴达维亚（Atavia），我想那是雅加达。那里疟疾非常非常猖獗。他们都病得很重。然后他们前往开普敦，他们都得了痢疾。所以这非常不幸，因为库克在整个旅程中都把他的手下照顾得很好。然后我想大约有30或40人在旅程的那个阶段死于疾病。
about the 20th, 22nd of August. And then where are they heading next? They head off to Atavia, which I think is Jakarta. It's very, very rife with malaria. They all fall terribly ill. And then they head off to Cape Town and they all get dysentery. So this is very unfortunate because Cook has looked after his men so well the whole journey. And then I think kind of 30 or 40 men die of disease on that stage of the trip.
但他们跑到了开普敦，前往英国，他们在1771年7月10日发现了兰兹角（Land's End）。他们在7月13日在迪尔（Deal）抛锚。就是这样，他们回家了。他们回来了。是的。万岁。所以他们回来时受到了相当大的赞许。库克与本杰明·富兰克林（Benjamin Franklin）共进晚餐，与詹姆斯·博斯韦尔（James Boswell）共进晚餐，后者当然是塞缪尔·约翰逊（Samuel Johnson）的传记作者，他对袋鼠的消息印象非常深刻。博斯韦尔记录了与约翰逊的一个非凡的夜晚，约翰逊模仿了一只袋鼠。没有什么比一个高大、沉重、表情严肃的人看起来更滑稽的了
But they ran Cape Town, head up to England, and they spot Land's End on the 10th of July, 1771. And they anchor off deal on the 13th of July. And that's it, they're home. They're back. Yeah. Hurrah. So they are greeted with considerable approbation when they return. Cook dines with Benjamin Franklin, dines with James Boswell, who is, of course, the biographer of Samuel Johnson, who is very impressed by the news of the kangaroo. And Boswell records an extraordinary evening with Johnson where he impersonates a kangaroo. Nothing could be more ludicrous than the appearance of a tall, heavy, grave-looking man
像约翰逊博士那样站起来模仿袋鼠的形状和动作，他站得笔直，把手像触角一样伸出来，把巨大的棕色外套的下摆聚拢起来，以模仿动物的育儿袋，在房间里做了两三次有力的跳跃，所以我喜欢那个，我喜欢约翰逊博士在房间里跳跃的形象，嗯，他被海军大臣介绍给国王，那是桑威奇伯爵（Lord Sandwich），我想是这样，是的，桑威奇伯爵，考虑到库克的背景，这太神奇了，但多米尼克，你知道那个被授予最高荣誉的船员吗。是约瑟夫·班克斯（Joseph Banks）吗，汤姆？不是约瑟夫·班克斯。
like Dr. Johnson standing up to mimic the shape and motions of a tall heavy grave looking man like dr johnson standing up to mimic the shape and motions of a kangaroo he stood erect put out his hands like feelers and gathering up the tails of his huge brun coot so as to resemble the poach of the animal made two or three vigorous boons across the room so i love that i love that image of dr johnson bounding across the room um he is uh cook is presented to the king by the first lord of the admiralty so that's um lord sandwich i think it is yeah lord sandwich considering cook's background this is amazing but dominic do you know the crew member that is garlanded with the greatest honour. Is it by any chance, Tom, Joseph Banks? It's not Joseph Banks.
不是吗？哇。那是谁？是那只山羊。哦，谢谢。当然是它。所以那只山羊现在已经环游世界两次了。是的。
It's not? Wow. Who is it? It's the goat. Oh, thank you. Of course it is. So the goat has now gone around the world twice. Yeah.
它是第一只做到这一点的山羊。它被誉为历史上最著名的山羊，并被授予荣誉。所以英国政府投票给这只山羊一笔养老金。海军部大臣给了她格林威治医院（Greenwich Hospital）养老金领取者的特权。这是唯一一次给予这样的荣誉，不仅是对任何山羊，而且是对任何动物。皇家学会给了她一个银项圈，她被放进了一个可爱的田野里，在那里她可以戴着她可爱的项圈啃食，非常快乐。约翰逊博士在山羊去世时，用拉丁文为她写了一篇悼词，这是翻译。
It's the first goat ever to do that. And it's lauded as the most famous goat in history and is garlanded with honours. So the British government votes the goat a pension. The lords of the Admiralty give her the privileges of an in-pensioner of Greenwich Hospital. And this is the only time that such an honour has ever been given, not just to any goat, but to any animal full stop. The Royal Society gives her a silver collar and she is put out into a lovely field where she can sit there with her lovely collar nibbling away and is very happy. Dr. Johnson, when in due course the goat dies, writes a eulogy to her in Latin, but this is the translation.
在名声上仅次于宙斯的护士，这只两次环游世界的山羊，值得她主人的关心和爱，现在已经找到了安宁和永久的牧场。这太感人了，但汤姆，我们的制片人西奥（Theo）问了一个许多听众都会想到的关键问题，这只山羊是被简称为“那只山羊”，还是它有一个名字？它确实有一个名字，但我们不知道是什么。从来没有人说过。哦，不。所以它只能被称为“那只山羊”。那只山羊，就像大卫或乔治。非常好。我认为这贬低了这只英雄般的记忆。确实。这是一个非常不公平的比较。漫游的山羊。所以汤姆，
In fame scarce second to the nurse of jove this goat who twice the world hath traversed around deserving both her master's care and love ease and perpetual pasture now has found that's so moving but tom theo our producer is asking the key question that will have occurred to many of our listeners is the goat referred to just as the goat or does it have a name? It does have a name, but we don't know what it is. No one ever says. Oh no. So it just has to be referred to as the goat. The goat, like David or George. Very good. I think that cheapens the memory of this heroic. It does. It's a very unfair comparison. Wayfaring goat. So Tom,
库克显然还有两次航行要进行，我们会谈到那些，不是吗？我们会谈到那些，我们可能会在明年的某个时候做，而且我认为公平地说，它们可能更不幸，当然第三次比第一次不幸得多，是的，第一次是传奇的，因为它是第一个时刻，英国人瞥见了澳大利亚和新西兰的海岸，并踏上了澳大利亚和新西兰。当然，这将产生不可估量的长期人口和地缘政治后果。这就是为什么库克船长被视为殖民主义罪恶的化身的原因。
Cook obviously has two more voyages to go and we will come to those won't we we will come to those and we'll probably do them at some point next year and there are perhaps i think it's fair to say more ill-starred certainly the third one is much more ill-starred than the first yes the first is the one that is legendary because it is the first moment where it's the first moment that an englishman has glimpsed the coasts of Australia and New Zealand and set foot on Australia and New Zealand. And of course, that will have incalculable long-term demographic and geopolitical consequences. And this is the reason why Captain Cook is seen as an embodiment of the evils of colonialism.
是的。为什么他的雕像……他被称为“库克骗子”（Captain Crook）。为什么他的雕像有争议。例如，悉尼海德公园（Hyde Park）里的他的雕像至今仍有争议。然而，从这两集中出现的画面，我会说，他不是埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernán Cortés）。
Yes. Why his statue- Captain Crook, he's called. Why his statue is controversial. His statue in Hyde Park in Sydney, for example, is controversial to this day. And yet the picture that emerges from these two episodes, I would say, he's not Hernán Cortés.
他根本不是科尔特斯。他不是一个贪婪的人，一个掠夺成性的人。当然，他确实在澳大利亚和新西兰这两个地方升起了英国国旗，并为王室宣称主权，我们的一些听众可能会说，哦，那是可耻的行为。但他的主要动机是好奇心和发现的快感，不是吗？你不觉得吗？我想事情是这样的，他知道，海军部也知道，
He's not Cortés at all. He is not a greedy man, a rapacious man. And of course, he does raise the British flag over both those places, Australia and New Zealand, and claim them for the crown, which some of our listeners may say, oh, that's disgraceful behavior. But his prime motivation is the thrill of curiosity and of discovery, isn't it? Do you not think? I suppose the thing is that he knows, and the Admiralty know,
有人会宣称拥有它。某个欧洲大国会宣称拥有它。所以我猜他的态度会是，我们最好是英国，而不是别人。他是英国人。我的意思是，他当然会那样想。那是18世纪的思想方式。他航行上去，然后继续前进。我的意思是，他不是在建立殖民地。他不是在带领武装探险队进入内陆。当然，不是库克提议将植物学湾用作罪犯流放地。实际上是约瑟夫·班克斯做了这件事。基本上，约瑟夫·班克斯，尽管他从未回到澳大利亚
that someone is going to claim it. Some European power is going to claim it. And so I guess his attitude would be, we might as well be Britain as anyone else. He's an Englishman. I mean, of course he's going to think that. That's the 18th century cast of mind. He sails up and then he moves on. I mean, he's not planting colonies. He's not leading armed expeditions into the interior. And of course, it's not Cook who proposes that Botany Bay be used as a convict settlement. That is actually Joseph Banks who does that. Basically, Joseph Banks, even though he never goes back to Australia
并把所有时间都花在英国，但他向英国政府建议了澳大利亚的殖民政策。所以可能是班克斯而不是库克更应该处于风口浪尖。我认为库克从这些航行中表现得非常好。是的，你已经成为一个真正的库克皈依者了，不是吗？你大约两周前给我发短信说你觉得库克船长非常无聊，你感到非常痛苦。我认为他确实很无聊。我的意思是，作为一个个体，我认为他很无聊，因为他太封闭了。但我认为他成就的规模，我的意思是，你只需要
and spends all his time in England, he's advised the British government on colonisation policy in Australia. So it's probably Banks rather than Cook that should be more in the firing line. I think Cook comes out of these voyages very well. Yeah, you've become a real convert, Cook, haven't you? You texted me about two weeks ago and said you found Captain Cook terribly boring and you were feeling very miserable. I think he is quite boring. I mean, as an individual, I think he is quite boring because he's so kind of close. But I think the scale of his achievement, I mean, you just have
把自己带回一个你不知道要去哪里的世界。你对外面有什么没有真正的概念。你对一船人负责。你必须与你根本不知道他们是谁、他们是什么、他们说什么语言或任何东西的人进行谈判。我认为在这种背景下，他成就的规模是不可思议的。是的。库克首先是一个科学人，不是吗？他是一个启蒙运动的人。我认为这是经常被忽略的事情。但我认为他超越了启蒙运动，我认为这才是感人的地方。他开始跳出启蒙运动优越感的框框去思考，即哲学家可以准确地将世界的所有多样性和多重性框定在一个
to think yourself back into a world where you don't know where you're going. You have no real sense what's out there. You are responsible for a ship full of men. You have to negotiate with people that you have no real idea who they are, what they are, what language they're speaking or anything. I think in that context, the scale of his achievement is incredible. Yeah. He's a man of science above all, Cook, isn't he? He's a man of the Enlightenment. I think that's the thing that is often missing. But I think that he out-thinks the Enlightenment, and I think that's what's moving. He comes to think outside the box of the Enlightenment sense of superiority, that a philosopher can accurately frame all the variety and multiplicity of the world within a
单一的系统中。我认为他开始认识到，欧洲的系统感必然不足以涵盖他所看到的事物的复杂性。我认为这就是感人的地方。他对人类有多丰富的理解在航行过程中不断演变。所以对于我们的澳大利亚和新西兰听众，我们将亲自与你们见面。当代播客的库克和班克斯。播客的。我们将在11月亲自与你们见面。
single system. I think he starts to recognise that the European sense of a system must be inadequate to embrace the complexities of what he's seeing. And I think that that is what is moving about it. His sense of how rich humanity is evolves over the course of his voyage. So for our Australian and New Zealand listeners, we will be with you in person. The Cook and Banks of contemporary podcasting. Of podcasting. We'll be with you in person in November.
坦率地说，汤姆，我等不及了。不，我也等不及了。我绝对等不及了。就在今天早上，汤姆和我还在讨论我们的旅行，我们即将前往新西兰的霍比屯（Hobbiton），那是库克船长和班克斯从未梦想过的地方。但我相信他们会喜欢的。所以我们下周会和听众见面，但我们很快就会在新西兰和澳大利亚见到你们中的一些人。实际上是真人。
Frankly, Tom, I cannot wait. No, I can't wait either. I absolutely cannot wait. This very morning, Tom and I were discussing our trip, our forthcoming trip to Hobbiton in New Zealand, a place of which Captain Cook and Tracer Banks could never have dreamed. But I'm sure they would have loved it. So we will be with you listeners next week, but we will be seeing some of you in New Zealand and Australia very, very soon. Actually in the flesh.
所以我们非常期待。所以非常感谢你们的收听。在各种方面，我们很快就会见到你们。再见。再见。很快就会见到你们。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论，
So we're looking forward to that hugely. So thanks so much for listening to this. And in all kinds of ways, we will be seeing you very soon. Bye bye. Bye bye. be seeing you very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一点演艺圈的八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的收听体验、奖励剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。